[Applaudissements]
pour patrick patrick comme je les dix
ans plusieurs fois c'est vrai comment il
fait partie du top 5 des animateurs
vraiment qu'ils ont compté à la
télévision pour moi il ya patrick
sabatier et à jean luc delarue
christophe dechavanne il ya bien sûr
jean pierre foucault et patrick
sébastien bref pour moi c'est les 5 5
chaque goutte faire exactement michel
qui est encore c'est un autre délire
enfin pour moi c'est encore réveillés
parce que lui c'est vrai que le poste
est même plaint des animateurs c'est
robocop il vole voilà le chêne drucker
mais c'est vrai que les cinq vraiment
pour moi c'est les 5 taulier 1 voilà je
pas si vous êtes d'accord avec moi et
donc on est très très heureux de t'avoir
patrick et aujourd'hui on va poser des
questions des questions à la société pmp
bien sûr tu aura le droit à un joker et
on joker ce sera valérie benaïm bon we
kara moment si tu dis action il arrivera
quelque chose à valérie benaïm a mal au
dos et bien écoutez c'est pas parce
qu'on a mal au dos on fait rien si on a
mal au dos on reste chez soi bien parler
et être à côté de moi à l on fait
plaisir
bof oui tout va bien se passer
alors si vous avez des questions bien
sûr vous n'hésitez pas juste avant
j'aimerais qu'on voit un extrait parce
qu'à l'époque il y avait une émission
que j'ai appris le jeu de la vérité
alors faire c'est pas le jeu de la
vérité un sort là c'est plus 1 1 voilà
c'est plus un action n'a été puisque je
vous dis leur inaction sur valérie
bénaïm et il ya un truc qu'on adore voir
celle extrait avec coluche qui avait
utilisé
il avait deux jours qui arrivent et de
joker pour la victime nord et coluche
nous il absolument dire toute la vérité
et le début regardez
première question 787 22-22 bonsoir
madame c'est à vous oui
bonsoir joker un joker deuxième question
787 22-27 avoue bonsoir joker
voilà maintenant les faits
alors vous pouvez poser des questions à
patrick bien entendu alors première
question on y va qui veut poser la
première question c'est christine qui
sait par quelle est la différence selon
vous aujourd'hui de la télévision par
rapport aux années 80 principale
différence
ben déjà ya beaucoup plus de chaînes
évidemment il ya beaucoup plus de
chaînes d'info donc c'est extrêmement
différents christine vous le savez bien
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup moins de
divertissement aujourd'hui qu'il y en
avait dans les années 80 et pour faire
court au niveau de la liberté de ton
bizarrement on se sentait plus libres en
1981 qu'aujourd'hui alors pour faire
court c'est vrai ça oui et les trucs que
vous auriez j'avais pu faire très juste
d'une part on pouvait parler pas de
problème d'interprétation du langage
voilà alors qu'aujourd'hui on doit faire
extrêmement attention parce que tout ce
qu'on dit peut-être classés dans cette
catégorie même si on ne veut pas donc il
faut faire extrêmement attention à ce
que l'on dit il ya plus comptabilité à
l'origine la spontanéité mais il faut
faire attention on va relancer puisque
s'il ne voulait pas encore dit mais h2o
relance ce pas une forme de jeu de la
vérité à partir de vendredi 25 janvier
lahrissi qu'ils y va s'appeler vendredi
vérité 60 minutes chrono et justement en
appelant tous ceux et toutes celles qui
voudraient venir
je sens que il ya ce qu'on va pouvoir
c'est différent voilà pas dire c'est
plus dur mais c'est différent on sent
bien que les gens se sentent un peu
coincé et ont peur de ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir dire à l'antenne avec des temps
ben oui valérie verhée alors pour
l'émission mercredi dont la votre invité
est cyril qui est également le
producteur de l'émission
oui est-ce que cyril a joué le jeu ou
est-ce qu'il a quand même malgré tout
parce qu'on le connaît il a il aime bien
contrôler les choses essayer dans votre
dos de contrôler des trucs de savoir des
petites surprises de savoir ce qu'ils
aient alestra mais son plateau dans mon
dos je suis pas parce que c'est en tout
cas ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
le deal a été respectée il est
producteur de l'émission il m'a laissé
totalement faire et tout ce que l'on
voit dans l'émission ne le savaient pas
d'ailleurs si tu devais pas venir des
choses qu'il dit en arrivant sur le
plateau glee c'est la première fois que
je produis une émission sans savoir ce
qu'il ya dedans donc je peux vous
assurer que on a eu beaucoup de
complicité avec ses copains je voudrais
saluer un parce qu'ils étaient
formidables qui s'appelle olivier
gabizon pas ce qui nous a aidés
faire l'émission et puis aussi vous
voulez rire on s'est vu un je me
souviens parce que je peux vous dire
c'est que cyril n'a jamais cherché à
savoir ce qu'il y avait dedans et si
vous regardez l'émission nous notre
challenge c'était de se dire que enfin
vous vous le connaissez bien moi
maintenant je peux dire que je me
connais bien parce que pour préparer
l'émission j'ai eu des copains j'ai vu
la maman j'ai vu le papa j'ai vu une
partie de la famille
j'ai vu des gens que vous avez voir dans
l'émission que vous même vous ne
connaissez pas donc je crois en moi je
le connaissais pas aujourd'hui
connaissent bien cyrille est ce que je
peux dire sans dévoiler quoi que ce soit
c'est l'homme que vous voyez à l'antenne
ce qu'on pourrait dire
il a fait beaucoup bah c'est l'homme qui
est dans la vie c'est à dire il est pas
aujourd'hui
de plus au moins 1989 puisqu'on a monté
en 1989 c'est un des rares hommes de
télévision parce qu'on ai pas beaucoup
je crois que j'en fais partie je me mets
avec lui mais un des rares hommes de
télévision qu'elle à l'antenne
exactement ce qu'il est dans la vie et
ça bravo parce que ça veut dire que les
caches voir la bande annonce mercredi
sur ces 8 regardez rendez vous chez
sabatier
regardez maintenant la faute aux clients
ce que tu as choisi 30 ans à pâques et
la non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la fête durera
pour lui c'est de prouver la cage du
rhône du groupe yum elle je t'explique
tout le monde voulait la pécho de la
classe m et toi tu es resté très très
fraîche
on va évidemment parler de cyril s'est
produit en moi il m'a remis mon année
scolaire
sarah se défoncer quand j'y pense et
beaucoup de copains bonbonnière qu'ils
deviennent nos souvenirs mais cyril
était dans votre glace jeu a vu qu'il a
fallu un petit peu de temps comme pour
me rappeler que à bercy ça va beaucoup
de surprises comme je vous le dis je
profite de cette émission pour te
témoigner mon affection mon amour et ma
fierté ma plus belle victoire c'est
quand je rencontre des gens dans la rue
king dit cyril tous les soirs on
t'attend et tous les soirs tu nous fait
marrer et une houe février notre journée
de merde
donc merci à vous qui va regarder qui
est d'après moi ce que vous mettez du
brouillard oui ça parce que c'est mon
sofa non non non je m'en fous que ce
soit vous vous retrouvez comme à
l'époque à l'hermine voir la photo là je
suis déjà dedans un jour qu'on se sent
bien avec patrick à 20 quand on s'assoit
on vous regarde patrick on est
tranquille on est bien on a envie juste
de passer un bon moment et c'est ce qui
nous fait passer patrick virginie book
est extérieur ce que ce genre de
missions que vous regardiez oui et puis
je trouve ça très touchant et puis je
vous vois aussi touché par regarder ça
et ça me donne envie de vous connaître
davantage parce que c'est vrai que je
vous connais à travers la télévision ce
qu'on dit de vous et le rythme mais je
dois bien avouer que vous êtes quand
même un des rares à venir toujours salué
les artistes quand ils sont dans les
loges pour ça je vous dis merci voir
s'engager
ce n'est pas patrick sabatier c'est une
carrière je voulais dire énorme
donc on vous a tout résumé en deux
minutes et on va continuer à vous poser
des questions regardant deux minutes
c'était dur mais regardez patrick
sabatier fait partie de ces animateurs
qui ont marqué la télévision comme
souvent tout commence par la radio après
un court passage par europe 1 patrick
sabatier commence réellement sa carrière
au micro d'rtl en 1976
[Musique]
quelques années plus tard il débute sur
tf1 en animant les visiteurs du mercredi
une émission jeunesse culte en direct
avec ses aléas je crois qu'il ya un tout
petit ennui technique vous voyez nous
nous sommes prêts je vous demande
quelques instants de patience en 1981 il
lance une émission qui deviendra culte
avis de recherche un grand
divertissement dont le but est de
permettre à des célébrités de retrouver
d'anciens amis à n'a pas le premier
appel donc trente ans après pour enrico
macias
il faudra attendre 1985 pour voir
apparaître sur nos écrans une création
de patrick sabatier qui reste
aujourd'hui encore dans les mémoires
le jeu de la vérité une émission dans
laquelle des célébrités viennent
répondre à toutes les questions des
spectateurs présents dans la salle et au
téléphone
bonsoir joker après une période plus
calme patrick sabatier fera son grand
retour à la télévision en 2008 sur
france 2 avec plusieurs émissions dont
mot de passe généralement c'est pour
cela que l'on joue c'est pour gagner en
2019 c'est sur ces huit qu'il revient
aux grandes pompes en animant vendredi
vérité et on se retrouve chez sabatier
les voilà trente ans plus tard
on espère que ces deux émissions
deviendront cultes comme leurs
animateurs
[Musique]
alors le paquet n'a pas franchement pas
avec tous les gens me disais tout à
l'heure il n'a pas changé il n'a pas
changé regarder alors on a fait regarder
on a vu l'évolution du look de patrick
howe et là on dirait qu'ils se
présentent au président patrick sabatier
regardé 60 et peut gérer 1995 lapointe
et fold j'adore rapprochement et non
franchement y'a pas vous dire pas changé
non mais non mais non on a d'autres
questions quand patrick et puis bien sûr
on a d'autres extraits des années 80 qui
est une question pour patrick vous il
demande oui on sait qu'avec nagui vous
entretenez une relation très compliqué
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
pourquoi c'est aussi tendu entre vous
deux alors la vie est courte donc je ne
vais pas perdre mon temps donc donnerai
pas de commentaire alors lorsqu'on on ne
renvoie en amont une petite vidéo de
nagui voilà on aborde tous les sujets
ici regardez il n'y a presque pas
d'accord il n'y a pas du tout et vous le
savez chaque fois que j'ai à ce micro
vous me posez exemple chaque fois je
vous redis nous on va pas relancer des
voix y avait appuyé le cas donc vous
n'avez pas envoyer un petit sms avec
désolé je crois plus avoir son numéro
je le donnerai fuel est cuisant oui car
bourne et je vais m'intéresser plus aux
gens que j'aime que le collège ce que
j'aime pas content c'est soit 1
apparemment il n'a pas oublié à voile
[Applaudissements]
mais bon voilà mais voulait pas réagir
patrick vous avez raison voilà aucun
commentaire aucun commentaire donc voilà
donc take-two là moi j'ai une question
pour vous d'avoir je contemple amara
doit regarder la dirif mon fils il parle
à ce triste parce qu'avant on disait pas
en disant on va regarder une émission
dit on va on regarde sa batterie ça que
le titre il est vachement grâce qu'on
disait pas où on va
je la verrai la cnce a tenu à mettre le
nom de patrick savatier dauphin de m
sabatier dans le titre mais c'était ce
qu'on disait avant 10 ce soir je regarde
sabatier de moi j'aurais vu ça après
quand vous allez arrêter la télé il ya
on vous voyez sur les affiches de bus on
vous voyez partout ceux rares tels
partout quand vous avez arrêté là tu es
comment vous avez fait pendant toutes
ces années ce que vous avez passé des
coups de fil aux gens ce que vous avez
disparu total et est ce que c'était dur
a assuré on en a beaucoup parlé avec
thierry parce qu'on s'est vus en dehors
de tout ça avec le recul j'ai pas
beaucoup de frustration j'ai eu des
envies a raté un mais pas de frustration
parce que j'ai une chance extraordinaire
on parlait tout à l'heure de c'était
quand la dernière fois les je disais
récemment moi d'avoir une femme
formidable
à la une famille extrêmement équilibrée
donc je peux dire que depuis le départ
il ya eu des hauts et des bas comme dans
toute carrière mais jamais de
frustration parce que à côté de ça à
côté de la télévision
une vraie vie équilibrée riche et je
dois dire que si les émissions s'arrêter
demain je ne peux pas dire que je suis
malchanceux
j'ai déjà fait tellement de choses qui
m'ont fait plaisir donc tout va bien
parce que ça veut dire vous n'avez pas
vécu dans par le prisme de votre métier
vous nous y penser voilà objets
terminant je rentre à la maison ma
famille est très important j'ai la
chance aujourd'hui les cheveux blanc et
d'or d'être grand père
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir des enfants
vous nous avons la chance de nous de
nous aimer les uns les autres d'avoir du
plaisir à être ensemble et franchement
dans la vie quand on fait des métiers
aussi aléatoire que le nôtre à ça ça
compte plus que tout il vaut mieux non
vous avez dit vous avez une femme et d
une famille équilibrée et je voyais
benjamin kayser qui sait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous voyez vous et moi aussi j'ai des
femmes et il a raison c'est la famille
pour ces moments là je fais une petite
parenthèse
j'ai revu les images il a inventé une
chose qu'on fait maintenant avec avis de
recherche était lundi mardi mercredi
jeudi et vendredi ont suivi l'évolution
d'une ère classe qu'il y avait un prime
le samedi alors dans les années 90 la
télévision c'est un peu comme dans tpm
pays c'est à dire beaucoup de problèmes
techniques
ah non avant j'aurais dû animer dans les
années 80 une vidéo ou dans une émission
où la chanteuse celio a énoncé de
chanter mais au niveau de la voix on
voit qu'il ya un problème
[Rires]
merci mes menus mais qu'il est mis on
espère qu'ils voudraient pouvoir laisser
passer aussi touché non il n'y avait pas
le show ils ont voulu se mettre dans
l'ambiance du magnéto est ce qu'on a une
autre question pour patrick benjamin
castaldi une question qui revenait un
peu dans le métier commenté sur vous
c'est sabatier il a des oursins dans les
poches
ouais ouais alors moi il m'a offert
plein de trucs ouais c'est ça c'est
vraiment pas quoi répondre à leurs
actions et après de moi même action ah
ben voilà donc ce que je sais pas
répondre à ça et ben voila je ne suis
jamais arrivé avait pas une rumeur mais
ne contrevient aux jeunes ont toujours
su allez venez maintenant on n'a pas le
temps à l'événement n'a pas le temps il
échappe à signaler le toit mais non mais
moi je vous collera de caprice bénin au
niveau 6 ballons venez vous aussi
pourquoi on a pris la plus grande
carrière et la plus petite
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous démarrez même lâché alors je vous
le dis c'était jure 4 tu ralentis au
monde
il y avait là il y avait une émission y
avait une émission qui était formidable
dans les années 80 et c'est à wii fit
des années 80 c'était le bébête show
eh bien on va seulement des bêtes
faudrait poser une question on a vu qu
lutte en jeu de la vérité mais en fait
la personne dont on avait le plus parlé
c'était chantal biya
avec le recul encore aujourd'hui elle
pense que vous l'avez admise dans un
piège que vous l'avait humilié et que là
je te faire long enfin j'ai alors est ce
qu'on a le droit de passer les images ou
pas je demande en régie parce qu'on les
hait ce qu'on a le droit de les passer
ben oui on a le droit oui alors lui qui
avec son cher mais on va les passer
je réponds à benjamin elles sont chères
mais l'argent n'est pas pour moi bah oui
alors alors là là là on prend là on n'en
met on va passer six matches que c'est
important c'est vrai que c'est un des
moments forts à la télé je voudrais
avant je peux dire quelque chose alors
ceux qui ne sont pas vous allez voir ça
13 décembre 1986 à sa place au palais
des sports de lyon mais c'est la énième
invités du jeu de la vérité on en avait
fait est appuyée de long et que lui chez
bien secours etc
et puis au mois de décembre chantal goya
qui fait un spectacle là bas avec
l'accord de toute son équipe pour faire
l'émission là-bas on sait exactement la
même émission que d'habitude ce que vous
allez voir moi moi moi moi même surpris
même tellement étonné et après je vous
je vous dit tout voilà alors on va on va
regarder les extraits voilà c'est après
que l'on dit pas d'un portail retourner
dans l'image les chansons de chantal
abêtissante et expliquer non un petit
peu ce que vous voulez dire moi c'est
moi
qu'elle aime pas vous allez pouvoir
répondre mais il est important également
que le téléspectateur puisse alors il
mais c'est très important alors à
l'usiné
non il s'attend pas à ce que vous dites
bon je demande mais les faits n'ont pas
d'âge ma petite dame vous devez
maintenir une forêt magique avec un très
joli arbres que les petits enfants sont
des petites souris autour de moi il ya
jeannot lapin elle valait tous rue
commines notre ami jeannot lapin
il aurait bien d'autres délits votre ami
jeannot lapin
il va chercher des noises est dans ta
casquette pour les enfants en cachette
notre ami jeannot l'appel alors après ça
a été serré alors juste les chéris parce
que vous avez pris une action il ya un
instant on va revenir dessus mais juste
là patrick alors ou après l'émission qui
ce qu'elle te dis bah déjà été très
content d'elle-même mais en plus je vais
vous dire deux trois choses très
importantes
moi je t'aime tellement bien que je lui
ai proposé de venir dans la nouvelle
formule
c'est vrai pour comprenez ça y est elle
a refusé
elle va faire un spectacle à la 76 ans
je lui souhaite bonne chance il n'aime
pas quelqu'un mais je trouve ça
formidable de monter sur scène et de
continuer son sale
donc je lui ai proposé de venir pour
promouvoir même ce spectacle a surpris
la chose qui ne va pas qui n'ira jamais
c'est que son attachée de presse de
l'époque qui s'appelait gilles paquet
qui malheureusement n'est plus là m'a
dit écoute vous devez vous réconcilier
donc nous avons fait venir dans une
autre émission last et tutrice
elles se sont vues elles se sont
réconciliées à l'antenne pour après un
tendre chantal dire mais c'était un
traquenard l'institutrice n'existe pas
mais on a fait une émission avec elle et
donc malgré le fait que cette
institutrice soit venu chantal
aujourd'hui le nid je crois qu'à un
moment donné elle a perdu la raison à
tous c'est très laid et l'a pas vu vous
n'a pas voulu voir la route comme si
avec ça a été un tournant
lire le championnat car si oui là il ya
des commentaires maman rap au coin du
bon sens et l'autre fairway chaud il ya
des analyses médias nous demander
pourquoi j'essaie de personnes tout
simplement parce que vous avez pris
d'action il ya un instant et habib sy
missions que s'est tenue le bébête show
dans les années 80 alors oui je vous ai
promis quoi ça va voir sa main vous
allez maintenant ça va voir tes les
marionnettes fait tout cas c'est
justement pour les faire preuve tout
octroi d émission des années 80 enfin
des extraits des années 80 nous rappeler
que jean luc lahaye voilà je suis
rappelé de la haie d'honneur y voir
quand ils raison de tina turner
c'est plus du tout question d'un trou de
mémoire de léon v comme moi à l'époque
regarde c'est enfin ce soir en
exclusivité vous offre son tout nouveau
clip et je vous demande d'être tout à
fait attentifs vous allez voir le nombre
d'image qu'il y a dans ce clip c'est fou
mademoiselle malades qui na tionale
tisha fétiche qui chante soir
[Musique]
si chaque parent vous allez l'entendre
tout jeune chanteur avant l'heure alors
moi qui bosse des miettes
voilà qui me tue à la tâche bravo bravo
les deux là les deux vous allez voir
vous allez voir alors est-ce qu'on
souvenez de l'école des fans pour damien
iehl mission version où les enfants
reprenaient des tubes de chanteurs et e
on dit voilà la vérité sort de la bouche
des enfants sont nés quand ils puaient
de la bouche
non mais ça c'est un sketch annoncé
valérie lemercier avec à la savoie parce
que le pauvre jacques martin voilà qui
était un des plus gros du magot nicolet
je vois je crois qu'il avait des métros
ça parce que c'est moi la petite fille
née papa a commencé son champ pôle il
boit de l'eau du vin j'en étais sûr
c'est un copain à moi combien il doit
par jour 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour autant luc de jodie maintenant on
voit du un peu cette impression va vous
donner voilà on va faire un top 5
finalement voilà 5 4 il reste encore
trois extraits j'ai changé des truands
oui on est comme ça et après il y aura
le bébête show very juste d'autres
questions pourquoi tricot aux causes oui
il ya des animateurs qui sur ces huit
ont fait des vrais retours gagnants
comme benjamin castaldi y en a dedans
julien courbet si oui lumière tombait
valérie bénaïm est aussi évidemment il
ya deux ans bien d'autres qui ont fait
des retours perdants on voulait dire
voilà il y en a d'autres qui ont eu plus
de mal à revenir ce que vous avez peur
pour mercredi soir
non j'ai pas peur parce que je veux plus
avoir peur pour faire de la télévision
pour moi ça doit être une partie de
plaisir j'espère que ce que l'on a fait
avec cyril bas à plaire au maximum mais
on a donné tout notre possible pour
vendre des vérités ça sera la même chose
non non non je ne veux plus je sais pas
si je le ferai encore six mois un an
deux ans trois ans marca je ne veux plus
avoir peur pour la télévision
j'ai donné avant qu'on ait la question
de mazarin castellini un autre extrait
aussi qu'on adore des années 80 c'était
donc c'est encore mieux l'après midi
avec christophe dechavanne que
j'embrasse qui accueille un étrange
animal sur son plateau un capybara capi
marin gros rongeur d'amérique big
[Rires]
brother d'amérique du sud m'a écouté est
détruite ou plates aurel bgc tenue même
de ce bail à lui et benhaim ans comment
s'appelle t c'est un capybara un
capybara c'est le plus gros rongeur du
monde qui vit en amérique du sud
il adore l'eau
animaux qui plombe c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon pour les animaux passer
vendeur les animaux qui plonge sais rien
il m'a juste aspergé de 2 litres de pipi
alors la réponse à ces deux personnes
pour la passe que dans 2 donc dans deux
minutes je vais voilà on va devoir se
passer un truc pour vous vous avez une
question vaut patrick savatier oui
j'aimerais savoir si à une période de
votre vie vous êtes en chantier un petit
peu démodé démodé non parce que je pense
je ne jamais avoir été à la mode
donc j'ai toujours fait ce que j'avais
envie de faire
puis quand on est partagé par le public
c'est formidable mais non non non je ne
m'occupe pas trop de la mode
si je dois dire vous allez voir les
missions qu'on a fait là pour mercredi
on a même repris les génériques il ya 30
ans à peu près le même style
ces jeux je passe trop la mode ça
m'intéresse pas parvenir la mode ce qui
m'intéresse est de partager des émotions
des sentiments ce que j'ai envie de
faire et puis faut surtout pas vouloir
faire le jeune quand on n'est pas saine
alors si je peux me permettre non j'ai
l'impression que vous ne l'apprécient
pas ça va durer que vous montrez de
tournez manège pour propos qu'on parlait
de retour gagnant à combien de
producteurs et la chaîne serait
satisfait mercredi
alors moi personnellement à 700 mille
téléspectateurs où on sera plutôt
content patrick alley je suis en ville
on sera très content un mineur
on sera folle aille très très très
content et à un million voilà je vous
dis on fera une très grosse fête l'anfr
fait ici son plateau il y aura pas très
constitué patrick si on est on est
d'accord c'est ça ouais enfin c'est tu
sais bien que moi là je touche du bois
je touche du bois alors si vous toucher
du bois niché plutôt la jambe de 950
vous allez voir ouais j'avais mal aux
lakers
en tout cas on a on espère parce que
l'émission
et vraiment bien moi j'y reviens pas
dessus donc pour vous dire qu'elle est
bien on va regarder
tournez manège rappelez-vous pour les
jeunes qui ne connaissent pas c'est
l'émission de dating
tu vois là sinon les candidats se voyait
pas ils s'étaient séparés par un mur et
parfois en fait il y avait des candidats
en plein d'amis n'arrive pas à assurer
sexuellement qu'un ceyrat arias o
je change un échange le premier coup
au monde quelque chose que tu fais le
plus dans la journée subi
c'est oui vous un peu plus légères j'ai
passé des questions juste savoir s'il
faisait plutôt un gros cube sikkim et
mourir alors je crois que j'ai un papa
poule argent l aider nous vous pourriez
vous dire combien vous avez touché pour
quelle a été votre salaire pour on se
retrouve chez sabatier non je ne dirais
pas
moi je ne parle pas d'argent alors il
alors elle va t il donc
action réaction
bah oui bah y aura deux actions passées
parti alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va c'est pas un petit bug faire
manger là